bonsoir et bienvenue dans qu'est ce que
votre émission culturelle alors au menu
ce soir la 17e édition du printemps des
poètes c'est du 4 au 29 mars où le site
de l'insurrection poétique
nous en parlons dans quelques instants
avec nos invités ni figé ni en tauride
l'oeuvre de l'allemand gluck est
présentée du 6 au 8 mars au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une tragédie
lyrique qui rend le texte est totalement
exclue des expositions tous dans le bain
c'est en ce moment au musée de la ville
et pour en parler mode l'argent dans la
chronique de nicolas gervais voilà ce
que vous pouvez découvrir dans ce
nouveau numéro de kiosques et on parle
tout de suite 17e édition du printemps
des poètes avec mes invités jacques
fournier bonsoir on se met dans la
maison de la poésie l'ubo cambon soir
dit un joueur disney cette d'elancourt
et godin bonsoir vous êtes rabeson il ya
quelques instants ce qu'est un rhapsodes
elle
la 17e édition du printemps des poètes
c'est donc jusqu'au 29 mars
acronis et quoi l'esprit d'un printemps
des poètes c'est la poésie partout c'est
vraiment mettre la poésie partout c'est
ce qu'ont fait finalement tout devient
finalement fait un printemps des poètes
toute la nuit le principe c'est quand
même deux pour la maison de la poésie
depuis 13 ans et d'être présent partout
sur tout le territoire et même au delà
avec le nôtre festival poésie yvelines
et toutes les opérations qu'on mène avec
le conseil général
mais c'est vraiment ça l'esprit et le
printemps des poètes est né en 1999 avec
cet esprit là de se rapprocher de la
fête de la musique on peut pas être dans
la même conception non plus puisque la
poésie et musique sont des univers très
différents
musique est quelque chose de très
extraverti la poésie par de l'intimé il
faut aller la chercher aussi
alors donc on nous on essaye de faire en
sorte que justement ce concept soit
vraiment bien appliqué sur le territoire
de saint paterne yvonne partenaires
voilà je crois qu'on en a une quinzaine
sur le festival cette année c'est parce
qu'au deuxième c'est pas l'idée non j'ai
pas dit ce garçon
une vingtaine de manifestations jusqu'au
29 mars
voilà une vingtaine de manifestations et
beaucoup de choses hors les murs on va
pas tout détailler mais orléans
justement parmi les partenaires et ali à
la signer cette d'elancourt on va
démarrer avec vous parce que ça démarre
tout de suite le 7 mars et samedi demain
avec les enfants du paradis
oui c'est la première fois qu'on
participe au printemps des poètes et
j'en suis très heureux et moi aussi donc
je remercie jacques parce que c'est vrai
que la poésie basse a traversé tous
voilà il ya beaucoup de poésie aussi
dans le cinéma il ya plein de cinéastes
voilà qui s'expriment aussi avec
beaucoup de poésie
donc on est ravis d'y participer et puis
on va donc projeté le chef-d'oeuvre
on va dire les enfants du paradis de
marcel carné avec barreaux arletty chez
terra donc samedi soir à 20 heures mais
ça commence à 19h ce cd d'une conférence
de carole aurouet non c'est ça la grande
spécialiste voit la limmat prévert c'est
qu'est-ce qui peut toucher dans cinéma
de prévert ben je crois déjà il ya un
esprit à l'espé d'insurrection qui là
aussi il va parler ça que je parle à sa
voisine
je crois que c'est ça c'est cet esprit
de l'insurrection quand on a nous on a
choisi des petits extraits de textes de
la cette année pour nos cartes postales
qu'on va distribuer les poèmes qui sont
dans les bus de ski bus depuis depuis
lundi il ya une phrase de colmar ce
convoi pendant tout le mois de mars lire
des poèmes
voilà et il ya cette phrase d'art
l'étiquette au début du film ou et dis
moi j'aime ça la liberté voilà c'est cet
esprit là et retenir cette simple petite
phrase d'arletty pour moi c'est
essentiel
bon il a tout dit je crois que les
enfants du paradis c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure à radio sensations
c'est je crois le film le film français
le plus comme on dirait j'ai eu le plus
culte qui parle de poésie qui est
empreint de poésie
but à la fin avec des dialogues
magnifique à scénario magnifique une
réalisation magnifique
donc voilà je crois que c'est le film
emblématique on pouvait pas faire mieux
si je puis dire
on sait s'habiller à partir de 19h ça
commence par une lecture référencement
conférence de carole aurouet qu'est la
grande spécialiste disait du cinéma de
priver du cinéma des poètes
elle sera accompagnée la compagnie pnv
belgrade sac avec laquelle elle
travaille beaucoup qui qui viendront là
pour ponctuer la conférence de quelques
lectures de textes de prévert et on fait
en fait cette projection pour une raison
bien particulière aussi c'est parce
qu'on va fêter quasiment jour les 70 ans
de la première projection mondiale du
film à paris en mars 40 alors à parler
bien non tout les manifestants on doit
comprendre quand même qu'elles sont
assez diverses donc là on est allé au
cinéma ça intéresse aussi les étudiants
la poésie puisqu'il y aura des
manifestations qui seront organisées
on va essayer de les intéresser à
l'université versailles saint quentin
notamment le 17 mars le 17 mars oui à
12h30 dans le hall du bâtiment vauban
vauban là on va mettre un petit peu de
vibrations dans les murs de l'université
puisque c'est à partir du projet all all
c'est un texte fondateur de la beat
generation écrit par allen ginsberg qui
a été un texte est plus une flore qui
est un texte époustouflant qui qui est
avec de dénonciation de du consumérisme
américain et la situation de l'amérique
des années 50 et et s'en sont emparés un
de ces gars les comédiennes et paul
aliot guitariste et qu'il n'ya pas avec
une guitare acoustique mais bien avec
une guitare électrique
donc voila quand on quand on a cherché
un petit peu savoir comment ce que ça
allait donner la flèche c'est mars à
12h30
nous avons aussi un extrait de van halen
pour nous dire voilà c'est ça que je
veux comme son jeu d'accord on essaie de
faire ça donc ça devrait intéresser les
étudiants ça de vrai et on espère
toujours et qu'on s'arrête aussi sur
notre journée celle du 21 mars c'est la
journée de la poésie ça va se passer à
guyancourt
il ya pas mal de moments forts oui il ya
un spectacle jeune public à la ferme de
bel ébat 11 heures à partir de textes de
françoise shanks qui est très
particulier très fort comme travail
comme projet de la part de des bruits de
la lanterne
ensuite il y aura plein d'animations à
la médiathèque jean rousselot qui ne
partenaires privés il ya le poids et
mathon oui le poleman
c'est un passé commun photo mc mois
on m'attend à poèmes ça y est vous
rentrez dans le poème on le voit là le
dos on vous dit un poème et quand vous
sortez vous récupérez le poème qui vous
a été dit c'est une compagnie de
lyonnaise qui a inventé ce concept et à
la photo dans son poème ah non il n'ya
pas la faute pour maya vers le soir on
termine avec les ouïes le bal des
insurgés avec charles gonzalez qui dira
des textes de poètes qui sauf qu'ils
connaissent l'insurrection et la musique
par le trio moss pour venir danser et là
il faut venir très nombreux comme je
disais tout à l'heure il faut refaire
traquer les murs pour montrer que la
poésie a vraiment sa place sur ce
territoire dont on conçoit insurgés ou
pas on vient tout le monde mais je crois
que tout le monde est un sujet tout le
monde à ce besoin de s'insurger
on va en parler de la surrection
justement avec higuain goidin ce sera le
28 mars pour l'insurrection poétique
alors vous présentez comme un rhapsodes
damman la première question c'est quoi
un rap sonne je me dis par ap sony
manière mais à l'évidence voilà en fait
rhapsodes c'est d'une phrase grecque qui
veut dire celui qui coulait zoo de celui
qui coule et chant et ils rhapsodes
c'est avant tout un nomade un glaneur de
poèmes donc j'ai la prétention de dire
au moins un poème dans 23 langues
différentes
voilà pas dans un but plein guise tic
puisque j'ai été glanés en rencontrant
les gens non rer en contrant des gens
dans des magasins qui sont devenus mes
professeurs de 2,2 de poésie en wolof en
bambara en lingala russe hébreu c'est ça
vous allez proposer samedi 28 mars à
sera dans le quartier des les merisiers
à partir de 15 et bien déjà c'est une
insurrection poétique dont le titre et
c'est toujours quand tu es là qui se
passe quelque chose
alors j'ai peut-être vous dire comme un
poème ce que c'est
apollinaire un jour et ce poème là qui
m'a habitée pour cette insurrection
apollinaire dit toutes les roses ne sont
pas roses
tous les sauts ne sont pas pleureur or
je sais des portes jamais close et des
héros qui ont toujours peur alors 7
jeudi j'ai dit dans la place de flaubert
saint-aubin flaubert et rab à la
librairie mille feuilles extraordinaire
à librairie de réinsertion je leur ai
dit ceci alors les gens sont ouverts ça
veut dire que j'ai peur de dire j'ai
peur d'apprendre
oui mais mangez pas j'ai pas peur
d'avoir peur voilà donc allons-y
ensemble et il ya plein de moments qui
va qui vont ponctuer l'avant l'avant
insurrection vendredi soir flaubert ou
les parents amènent un repas et nous
allons déguster les mots de mahmoud
darwich et puis le samedi 7 place du
marché où nous allons questionner clamé
murmurer des dépôts elle vous sera
partir c'est samedi 16 ohms à sa place
au poème avec avec la collaboration de
la merise mais il y aura aussi surtout
nationale insurrection à 17,28 messine
l'insurrection ne peut pas avoir lieu si
vous n'êtes pas là pour kiel pour
qu'elle se passe il faut vraiment coudre
avec les gens et rhapsodes c'est la
couture amener les gens se dire bas -
voilà je fais
parti de cette insurrection sans moi
elle ne peut pas avoir lieu
voilà qui va d'ailleurs donc les gens
viennent les gens viennent répète des
poèmes que nous allons scander à y est
les enfants d'aider les adultes de deux
mille feuilles ont déjà commencé à
prendre ce poème et puis des gens petit
à petit en marchant vont continuer à
s'en emparer et donc les gens fassent
parvenir à même s'ils n'ont pas fait
partie des ateliers peuvent encore venir
gens peuvent être ça c'est samedi 28
mars à partir de 15 heures dans le
quartier 17h10 automne 7h17 peut-être du
carnaval de trappes d'accord à partir de
17h le samedi 28 mars avec la compagnie
difé kako quand même qui est
extraordinaire et qui va donner
qui va nous apporter son rythme et nous
allons les les embrasser alors voici
quelques unes des manifestations qu'on
peut découvrir à l'occasion du printemps
des poètes vous êtes enflammé c'est
formidable
donc voilà quelques-unes des
manifestations qu'on peut découvrir à
l'occasion de la 17e édition des
partants des pâtes mais ya encore plein
de choses qu'on peut trouver évidemment
sur le site internet voilà la maison de
la poésie avaya des choses partout sur
tout le territoire merci beaucoup à vous
trois c4 une annulation sur le plateau
de kiosques on va poursuivre ce magazine
maintenant avec une page musique
et une création présentée au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines les 6 7 et 8
mars iphigénie en tauride après gluck
une tragédie lyrique en quatre actes
mise en scène par jacques osinski
interprété par les solistes de l'atelier
lyrique de l'opéra de paris nous avons
suivi les dernières répétitions
le ton est dramatique la mise en scène
volontairement sobre les paroles en
français
l'oeuvre de gluck du xviiie siècle
détonne avec les variations lyrique du
bel canto du 19e iphigénie en tauride
est présenté au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines mise en scène
par jacques osinski nous sommes dans
l'esprit de la tragédie grecque adapté
au chant lyrique
c'est comme si c'était un test de
théâtre avec musique
il n'y a pas une note en trop chacun
aurait justifié son parent comme au
19ème siècle à l'opéra des états d'âme à
réguler bel canto ou des airs et c'est
là c'est vraiment un rituel comme ça
quelque chose de très épuré très sombre
le texte et la musique très imbriqué
rien ne prend le pas sur l'autre dans
cette histoire où une jeune femme est
partagé entre deux amis
nous comme au mans où il écrit cette
partition est véritablement dans une
dans une réflexion sur les liens qui
peut y avoir entre le texte et la
musique certes mais aussi entre la
tragédie à l'efficacité dramatique à la
musique et c'est d'autant plus important
pour lui qu'il ait entend véritablement
s'opposer à des gens qui n'ont pas
exactement les mêmes convictions kuip
lui-même et en allemand mais défend une
esthétique qui se base sur on va dire à
la fois sur sa rigueur d'allemand et en
même temps sur toute la tradition
française pour chanter les textes et
d'iphigénie en tauride les jeunes
solistes de l'atelier lyrique de paris
un vrai challenge pour eux c'est un très
beau texte français c'est parmi les
derniers grand louvre est littéraire en
langue française dans notre répertoire
car au 19e siècle après ce sera beaucoup
plus plu livret d'opéra dans ce cas nous
avons un très beau texte qu'il est très
émouvante
iphigénie en tauride à découvrir au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines du
6 au 8 mars
et puis toujours en musique et voici
quelques dates à retenir tout d'abord ce
concert qui sera donné dimanche 8 mars
au scarabée de la verrière par fatoumata
diawara lors se son nom ne vous est
peut-être pas inconnue elle a joué et
chanté dans le film timides ou archi
césarisé elle participe à un concert
dans le cadre de la journée de la femme
sa voix est envoûtante et je vous
propose justement un extrait
m
d
prenez
mais à la mer
on va changer maintenant d'horizon avec
ce concert de musique classique des
xviie et xviiie siècles donné ce samedi
à 18 heures au temple de montigny le
bretonneux par l'ensemble qui est l'état
au programme des oeuvres de beurre de
purcell et haendel la participation est
libre
encore un autre univers de la pop du
rock de l'électro ce samedi 7 mars à la
batterie à guyancourt dans le cadre du
temps des femmes la scène féminine
française sera mise à l'honneur avec
trois groupes qui ne passent pas
inaperçus les fils punchy de théodore
paul et gabriel la sauvage et fragiles
ou remarque qu elle est déjà bien connu
autour de lucie tarifs à partir de 10
euros 50
et puis un dernier rendez vous à ne pas
manquer à la merise de trappes l'
orchestre manifesto dirigée par mélanie
lévy thiébaut sera en concert donc à
20h30 au programme de la musique
classique romantique de la fin du xviiie
siècle et des rythmes à caractère
espagnol du début du 20e siècle
la violoniste marianne piketty jouera
des morceaux pendant à cette
représentation aux joues roses de
l'écouté justement au micro de tv fils
un concert avec david guerrier qui est
victoires de la musique qui est une star
qui jouera ce qui est exceptionnel il
joue aussi bien de la trompette que du
corps dont qui jouera humaine le tube de
du répertoire de trompette et moi je
jouerai le concerto de mendelssohn ainsi
que des pièces courtes les airs
bohémiens de sarrasin et c'est très
important pour nous parce que la pms q
donc l'association pour la promotion de
la musique à saint quentin en yvelines
le désire vraiment ce qui fait vraiment
vibrer son président hervé charge c'est
d'apporter la musique à tous
maintenant je crois qu'on a commencé en
2000 ou 2001 donc ça fait presque 15 ans
et 15 ans a fait que le projet existe et
ce qu'ils ont réuni je pense aussi bien
le public sait sont des liens humains et
je pense que c'est ça qui partageait
aujourd'hui tout de suite on va
retrouver la chronique de nicolas
gervais cette semaine il a rencontré
mots de marchands qui nous parle de la
nouvelle exposition du musée de la ville
tous dans le bain
et bonjour et bienvenue dans le coeur
aujourd'hui nous intéressons à
l'évolution des salles de bains et de la
toilette au 20e siècle
c'est avec la nouvelle exposition du
musée de la ville intitulé tous dans le
banc en une exposition vraiment bien si
vous venez vous verrez vous pouvez vous
faire mousser et sinon à comprendre à st
nom la manière de se laver a
profondément changé depuis
depuis un siècle environ le fait de
faire sa toilette comme on le fait
aujourd'hui c'est à dire en prenant des
bains des douches régulier avec de l'eau
chaude et bien c'est quelque chose qui
est assez récent et c'était assez rares
il ya 100 ans à peine
on prenait son bain dans une cuvette de
manière assez sommaire au mieux une fois
par semaine dans les années 50 par
exemple sur un territoire qui allait
devenir celui de saint quentin en
yvelines
mais tous les logements n'avaient pas
encore de salle de bains et c'est pour
ça que le musée de la ville a décidé de
d'ouvrir en grand la porte de cet espace
qu'un espace un peu intime quand même et
d'aller voir ce qui s'y passait dans les
années 30 dans les années 50
et puis dans les années 70 jusqu'aux
années 90 il y avait tout un imaginaire
qui était lié à la non propreté à la
crasse par exemple on refera jusqu'à la
fin du 19e siècle on avait des
réticences à prendre des bains alors
d'une part parce que il y avait un tabou
lié à la nudité
quand on se baignait et on se baignait
que pour des raisons midi médicale on ne
se dévêtaient pas complètement mais
aussi parce qu'on croyait que l'eau et
est vectrice de maladie et parce que
elle nous débarrasse est d'une couche de
crasse que l'on croyait protectrice
le changement se fait au début du siècle
avec une demande qui est croissantes en
matière d'hygiène avec des nouvelles
politiques d'hygiène publique
mais c'est seulement au tournant des
années 50 avec la reconstruction que les
salles de bains apparaît sans les
logements lorsqu'ils changent c'est
cette demande d'hygiène et c'est aussi
là que c'est beaucoup plus facile à
l'eau courante
jusque dans les années 50 sur le
territoire toutes les communes n'étaient
pas reliés à l'eau courante à guyancourt
elle est installée que dans les années
30 jusque là il fallait le chercher son
eau puis fallait la faire chauffer sur
la gazinière
le musée de la ville a demandé à des
habitants de nous raconter leurs
souvenirs leurs anecdotes leur façon de
penser la toilette il ya une vingtaine
d'entre eux qui ont répondu qu'ils ont
accepté de nous laisser rentrer et grâce
à ça on a réussi à comprendre quelles
étaient leurs gestes de la toilette les
souvenirs à retrouver des produits
anciens mais aussi on a mis des extraits
en scène dans l'exposition sous la forme
de douches sonores
donc c'est à dire qu'on entre dans un
espace on se place sous la douche on
appuie sur le robinet et on a ce flot de
paroles qui sort avec des témoignages
qui sont souvent assez émouvant il ya
deux parties dans l'exposition donc à
l'étagé on a quatre constitutions de
salles de bains une des années 30 est
plutôt une cuisine il ya celle des
années 90 ce qu'est notre grande salle
de bains d'aujourd'hui et on passe entre
ces deux moments là par la baignoire
sabot des années 50 qui est juste
derrière et par le biais des roses des
années 70 s'est accompagnée de documents
d'époque surtout des publicités
anciennes et aussi de plans d'architecte
qui sont liés au territoire
spécifiquement saint quentinois qui
montre comment la salle de bains est
arrivé dans les intérieurs et comment
elle s'est développée comment elle s'est
agrandie sa place par rapport à la
chambre
on s'est rendu compte que c'était un
thème qui était assez drôle donc on a
rendu compte de on a fait plein petit
clin d'oeil dans l'exposition
il ya des jeux à destination des adultes
et des enfants et dans la médiation
c'est une nouveauté au musée de la ville
pour la visite
il ya des parcours pour adultes et pour
enfants sur tablettes tactiles
au rez-de-chaussée c'est le cabinet de
curiosité c'est notre cabinet de
curiosités on a rassemblé tous les
objets un peu étonnant souvent très
drôle qu'on a qu'on a vu qu'ils font
partie de notre imaginaire la salle de
bain il ya aussi des oeuvres d'art donc
par exemple visiteur y trouvera des
objets détournés des robinets des
robinets réversible des brosses à dents
hydraulique une galerie de ses cheveux
et une exposition de baignoires
insolites et des certaines oeuvres d'art
d'artistes du territoire
voilà quatre signés avant de vous
retrouver en plateau trois dates
d'ateliers à retenir pour rester dans le
bain en famille le 7 mars le 11 avril et
le 22 avril
toutes les dates tous les renseignements
c'est sur le site du musée de la villa
bientôt aller comme tous les mercredis
jeux provenant de retrouver la chronique
cinéphiles et nous débutons évidemment
par les avis de spectateurs au micro de
10 mois née cette semaine les avis se
sont portés sur le firme shapira film de
science fiction
les effets spéciaux sont formidables et
puis c'est le genre de film qu'on peut
qu'adorer quoi ça
ça bouge dans tous les sens et c'est
bien fait c'est très bien l'histoire en
général les films les effets spéciaux
schapi l'histoire enfin il ya un sujet
qui est intéressant c'est le transfert
de la confiance en soi c'est très bien
c'est un film
sur l'a10 sur l'a1 intelligence
artificielle et c'est bien sûr que le
film est bien tournée pourrait très bien
car bon film de science fiction
et puis les acteurs sont bons bon il ya
une histoire à une histoire de
sentiments les robots deviennent
sentimentaux un peu on transmet tous les
deux tout le cerveau toute l'âme dans
dans un robot et nous poursuivrons avec
le coup de coeur d'un professionnel du
septième art ce soir pineau du grenier
de trappes
bonjour cette semaine je voudrais vous
parler d'un film que l'on passera samedi
soir donc ce sera samedi 7 à 20h45
il s'agisse du film thx thx 11 38
le premier film de george lucas qu'il a
tourné en 1971 et qui est un film qui
est devenu un film culte
samedi soir nous présenterons dans le
cadre d'un ciné philo c'est un peu la
première fois qu'on fait ça et ça sera
avec le un philosophe et enseignant qui
s'appelle xavier papaïs il est
enseignant à l'école normale supérieure
et philosophe
le thème de cette soirée ciné philo ce
sera la déshumanisation la société de
contrôle puisque l'histoire de thx
c'est justement une société hyper
contrôlée ou
un homme qui
s'appelle thx 11,38 puisque ça se passe
au 25 par 25ème siècle et que les hommes
et les femmes sont répertoriés par des
noms part dénombré des numéros donc ce
fameux thx 1138 a commis une erreur
incroyable avec une autre femme
il a couché avec elle et c'est interdit
voilà donc ça va on est plein de
questions ce sera
ce samedi 7 à 20h45 pour trouver tout ça
sur notre site internet www cinéma le
grenier à sel point com merci à samedi
avant de terminer que ce que propose
maintenant de découvrir quelques images
du prochain film de jamais deux mousses
pourquoi j'ai pas mangé mon père sortira
enfin le 8 avril un film d'animation
réalisé de poncins trappistes c'est la
première fois d'ailleurs que vous passez
derrière une caméra ou une question sur
fond de comédie de l'exclusion des
jeunes et ce matin jamais debout était
l'invité d'europe 1 il est notamment
revenu sur la polémique autour des
restos du coeur autour de la dernière
chanson des qui met en scène
des jeunes critiquant leurs aînés
célébrités et anonymes et ils sont
nombreux à la jugé réactionnaire
ce qui n'est pas le cas de l'humoriste
neuf des cris c'est formidable les
restos du coeur on doit soutenir les
restos du coeur corps et âme qu'est ce
qu'on vient de faire chier les restos du
coeur au legends il donne à manger à des
gens qui ont faim qui ont soif visite ou
quoi si les gens qui perdent du temps
par les mâles des restos du coeur sont
des hommes sont des inconscients
voilà le coup de gueule jamel debbouze
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivis rendez vous mercredi
prochain donc à la même heure nous
parlerons du festival à tout bout de
champ à magnifier les hameaux d'ici là
regardez l'esprit ouvert et curieux
notoire et bonne semaine